>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Jo Reed: Welcome everybody,
I'm Josephine Reed, I produce
and host the weekly podcast
for the National Endowment
to the Arts, called Art Works.
Which you can check out at arts.gov,
where you can also find our fabulous
blog and short documentaries
about arts throughout the country.
So there's the shameless
plug for the NEA.
I want to, thank you, welcome to a
conversation about legacy and novels
with Julia Glass and Jennifer Haigh.
This is going to be the shortest
intro ever so, Julia Glass.
Her most recent book is
a House Among the Trees.
The story of a relationship
between a celebrated recently
deceased children's writer
and his assistant.
Which is further complicated
by his wishes
for the disposal of his estate.
Julia is the author
of five previous books
of fiction including Three
Junes, her debut novel
which won the National
book Award in 2002.
Julia has received a number
of fellowships including one
from the National endowment for
the Arts in creative writing.
Jennifer Haigh's most recent novel,
Heat and Glass has just
come out in paperback.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Heat and Light.
>> Jo Reed: And she returns to
the Pennsylvania town of Bakerton,
where the issue of fracking
is upending the community
and folks there are
slowly discovering
that what they were promised is
not necessarily what they're going
to get.
Jennifer is the author of the short
story collection, News From Heaven
and four novels including
Baker's Towers and Mrs. Kimble,
which won the PEN/Hemmingway
Award for debut fiction.
And Jennifer is also a
recipient of a fellowship
in creative writing from the NEA.
Okay so we know who
we are so let's begin.
First of all when I'm
thinking about legacy and Julia
in your books there's the
personal legacy in the possessions
of Mort Lear, your author
and then the literary legacy
that he leaves behind is impact
on generations of children.
And Jennifer with your book it's
the legacy basically of geography,
what the earth leaves
us and how we use it
and then how previous macro
decisions about energy.
Factors into what we're
looking at today.
So I actually think it's a
really fruitful conversation
on both the micro and
the macro level.
Julia I'd like to start with
you simply at the beginning
about what draws you to a
particular idea for a novel?
>> Julia Glass: So my novels
don't start with ideas,
they start with characters and
there are many different ways
that different authors approach
the material they're working with.
But for me this novel
started because I happened
to read an article in the New York
times that was published short
after the children's book
author, Maurice Sendak died.
And it focused on how the
will he left behind was not
at all the will which was expected.
In fact, he completely scorned
this museum in Philadelphia
which had reason to believe
they were going to inherit all
of his art work and
he left them none.
Now but the part of the article
that interested me the most was
that the executor who was to carry
out all these wishes was a woman
who had lived in his house with
him for many years starting
out as his dog walker, becoming
probably his professional assistant
and then became I think
in his older years,
probably a domesticate help maid.
And there was a lot of criticism
from the literary world,
that who was this woman.
She couldn't possibly be
qualified to undertake, you know,
to shoulder the legacy
of this great man.
And I just thought about her and I
thought what would it be like first
of all to live your life in service
to a genius, to a great artist.
What's it like to be in that
orbit or centrifugal force
and then what would it
be like to be left not
with just the material legacy but
with the reputation especially
if secrets emerged as they
often do after someone dies.
What do you do with the
things you find out,
does the world deserve to know them.
And as you know the plot is
also complicated by the fact
that the artist in my
book, who is inspired by
but not based on Maurice Sendak.
His name is Mort Lear, there was a
movie in development to do a biopic
about his life and the after cast to
play him had been in correspondence
with him and was expecting
to meet him
and the novel begins the
day that actor arrives.
When instead he has
died quite suddenly,
ten days before the
assistant and the actor meet.
>> Jo Reed: And I'm
glad you brought that up
because one thing I
really did want to ask you,
you had Tommy the assistant and
Meredith the jilted museum curator.
And I think most authors at point
would say that's pretty you know,
plenty of conflict, let's just
call it a day and focus on them.
But you bought in that third leg.
You brought in Nick Green who
added just a lot of richness
and complications to the book.
What made you go in that direction
and bring that character in?
>> Julia Glass: That's a bit of
a long story but I should say
that I have a 21year old son who
is passionately involved in acting.
All he wants to be is an actor
which they say is the only way
to approach being an actor, it
better be the only thing you want.
And you can imagine I'm a
little frightened about that
because all my friends say I'm not
in a position to discourage a child
from following their creative
urges, so good luck to me.
But it really grew, Nick
Green's character really grew
out of conversations and
arguments with my son about actors
and their portrayals and
what does being an actor
and how you portray a real, whether
that person is living or dead.
And as any of you who go
to the movies know a lot
of films these days are biopics.
Whether they're about Alan
Turing or Stephen Hawking
or painter Turner or Steve Jobs.
I mean that is a very big part
of our film story telling now.
And in a way the actor also
holds the legacy of that person
in their hands when they
approach the performance.
>> Jo Reed: Jennifer in
the case of Heat and Light,
this is the third time that
you've returned to Bakerton,
can you tell me how your geographic
roots really inform your work?
>> Jennifer Haigh: My three Bakerton
books are very much about a place,
they're stories that could
not have happened anywhere
but in this little coal town
in western Pennsylvania.
I call the town Bakerton, it's
very much modeled after the town
where I grew up in Cambria County,
Pennsylvania called Barnesboro.
And this location, this town
of Bakerton has really become a
character of mine and it's one
that I return to again and again.
The first Bakerton book
was called Baker Towers
and it was my second novel.
It was set in the 1940s and 50s
when the coal mines were booming
and the town was vibrant.
That to me was a story I always
wanted to tell because you know,
by the time I was growing up
in the 70s and 80s it was all
over for coal mining in
my part of Pennsylvania.
And all these stories that I had
heard about the glorious past
of this town were just stories.
So I think that novel grew out
of my desire to time travel back
to those years to see
what it was really like.
You know, there's a character in
Heat and Light who is thinking
about his town and he said
the town is all aftermath.
And that is very much my
experience growing up in that town,
it had already seen better days.
So I wrote a book about
those better days.
Baker Towers published in 2005
and for a long time I
thought okay, I did it.
I said everything I had to say about
this town, I time travelled back
to the glory days, okay done, I
can go write about something else.
And I did, I wrote two more novels
set in Boston where I live now
and I thought I was
done with Bakerton.
But you know, in those years
a funny thing happened.
I found myself thinking about some
of the characters in Baker Towers
and wondering how their
lives turned out.
I mean that for me is
what novels are about,
how people's lives turnout and
so I gave myself permission
to write a short story,
one short story.
About Joyce Novak who is the
main character in Baker Towers.
And that story led me
to write another story
about her brother Sandy who is sort
of a mysterious figure
in Baker Towers.
And I wanted to write a story to
let readers know what he was really
up to, what were secrets.
And so each of these
Bakerton stories led me
to write another Bakerton story
and pretty soon I had a collection
of ten of them all set
in or around this town.
Those stories I call
News From Heaven,
really deal with what
the aftermath was.
What was it like to live in
that town after the mines died,
after the towns reason
for being had dried up
and blown away, then what happens.
How do people find
a way to continue.
And so that was very much
the question at the center
of those stories, News From Heaven.
So after that I thought
okay now I'm really done.
Because clearly nothing else is
ever going to happen in this town,
I'm done, there is no more.
And right around that time
this fracking story started
to be all over the news.
And I'm sure many of you
have been following this
in the early 2000s there
was a lot of conversation
about natural gas drilling in
Pennsylvania, New York State,
West Virginia, Eastern Ohio.
This formation called
the Marcellus shale.
Geologists had known for 100
years that it was down there
but until recently we did not have
the technology to extract that gas,
there was just no way to get to it.
That changed in the 90s
when Halliburton developed this
technique of hydraulic fracturing.
They at first used it on oil wells
but then they found this was also a
way you could extract natural gas.
And so for this regions of
Pennsylvania where it seemed
to be all over there was suddenly
this new possibility that a lot
of people were very excited about.
That you know, for people who
had been mourning the death
of the coal industry for a
generation it seemed like oh,
for the first time in 30
years we have good news.
There's opportunity for people here.
There are going to be jobs,
there's going to prosperity again,
so it was really greeted
with a great deal of hope
by people in western Pennsylvania.
Of course as you all know
it's not quite that simple,
there's also a case against
fracking, that, you know, is real.
There are legitimate
environmental questions
about the safety of fracking.
So there has been a real
heated argument going
on about the advisability of
fracking in the Marcellus shale.
So Heat and Light is a story
about what happens to a town
when they yes to fracking.
When the gas industry moves in,
when people are leasing the
mineral rights to their land
and how life changes
for everybody involved.
So this is a surprise third
act to my Bakerton story
that I wasn't expecting
ever to write.
It was just a book that life gave
me and that happens sometimes
when you're writing novels.
There are books that
life just gives you.
If you're paying attention
to the world around you,
sometimes a novel just about
drops down on your head
and that's what Heat and Light was.
>> Jo Reed: I find with
both of your books they seem
to be asking many questions but
among them it's what do we value,
what do possessions mean?
What dreams do we have,
what dreams do we let go of?
What do we do in the
pursuit of those dreams?
>> Julia Glass: Well, you know
that's and interesting way to look
at it but I actually want talk about
something a little bit different
and I also want to ask Jennifer
about it and it has to do
with the choices that
we make in life.
I found myself having a conversation
with my older son the other night
where I said to him, we
were walking about --
he'd seen a movie and the
character obviously had regrets.
And I said you know, honey as
you grow older you will find
that you will have regrets.
I said if anybody tells you
that they have no regrets
they're either very shallow
or they are lying to you.
And I was thinking about
choice and I always talk
about the choices my characters
make and how they guide the plot.
I write ahead into the dark
and so one of the things
in my book is not just what
do the characters value
but what why have they
made the choices they made
that have led them to this moment.
And which choices do they
look back on as choices
that maybe they shouldn't have made.
And one of the things that I
really loved about Heat and Light,
and by the way as someone who
writes from character and I teach
and I teach my students
that characters are --
they're the meat of the story.
I just was blown away by how many
fully real life characters are
in Heat and Light.
And as I wrote to Jennifer
after I finished it,
I loved the first character.
Even though he is very morally
complicated man because he's trying
to get these people to sign
these leases for the fracking.
And then I saw that I was
going to another character
in the next chapter, I thought
wait a sec I really wanted
to be back with that character.
Then I was in love with
the second character.
But the really important
things it seems to me in Heat
and Light is the whole issue
of the choices that we make.
And what happens when the choices
that one person makes conflict
with the choices that a
neighbor makes or a spouse makes.
And there's you know, a lot of
turmoil emerges from the choices
that are suddenly forced
on this community you know,
by this company that comes in.
The stranger that comes to town.
>> Jennifer Haigh:
Yeah, exactly right.
>> Julia Glass: I mean did
you plot everything out,
I mean I need to ask [cross-talk] I
was just at Truman Anderson's thing
and I had actually
never heard this before
but somebody asked him are
you a pancer or a plotter?
Do you know that term pancer?
Well, he said oh yes
well for those of you
who don't know that's a writing term
that means do you plot your book out
or do you write from
the seat of you pants?
So I just found out I'm a pancer.
So are you a pancer
or are you a plotter?
>> Jennifer Haigh: The answer
to that question is yes.
>> Julia Glass: Both.
>> Jennifer Haigh: I am
both of those things.
Because here's what happens, when
I'm writing a novel I never think
about plot, I don't
even use that word.
What I think about is causality,
that every time an event happens
in the story it has to have
a consequence that leads
to another consequence, that
leads to another consequence.
So really what I'm doing is I'm
writing kind of a flow chart
of the consequences of
choices people make.
So to me you know, plot is
something that writers inflict
on their characters and causality
is something that happens
on its own in this organic way.
That every event has ripples and
those ripples lead to other ripples
and so I may invent the first event
but then what I'm doing is thinking
of all the penumbra of
possible consequences
of that event and choosing one.
And then I do the same
thing over and over again
and that's how the story gets built,
so I'm kind of a pancer in the sense
that I'm just going as
far as the next choice.
And then I just play out
the consequences of that.
So I don't know it's a middle path.
>> Julia Glass: Right but
the plot in Heat and Light
or the story I should say has many
moving parts, partly because it has
so many characters making so many
different choices and the writer
in me as opposed to the reader
in me was just wondering,
did you know where
you were going to end?
Did you know, because it's a story
with a real moral backbone
but not heavy handed.
So did you know where it
was going to come out?
>> Jennifer Haigh: I
did and I was wrong.
That's usually what happens to
me, I usually think I have an idea
where I want it to go
but I'm always wrong.
So this was a book that was a
very hard thing for me to hold
in my hands, it was like trying
to hold water in your hands.
When I started writing it
I thought I writing just
about this fracking controversy
but as I wrote I realized
that the story was much,
much larger than this.
That in this part of the world
and this is a line from the book
that Pennsylvania is
what lies beneath.
It is a place whose destiny has
been determined by its geology.
You know, the first oil well
in the world was drilled
in western Pennsylvania,
most people don't know this.
Then we had 150 years
of coal mining,
we had deep mines,
we had strip mines.
We had the Three Mile
Island nuclear disaster.
So throughout its history
Pennsylvania has really been living
the story of energy and
that's what Heat and Light is.
And it's a story that I do
go to Three Mile Island,
I do go back to the days of drilling
oil in the 1850's in Pennsylvania.
Because there's simply no way
to understand this story except
by looking at its context,
this fracking thing
didn't happen in a vacuum.
Pennsylvania has been down this
road before and before and before.
And when you think about where we
get our energy in this country,
it's always coming
from the same region,
it's always the same communities
that are kind of left
holding the bag.
That is West Virginia and Western
Pennsylvania and Eastern Ohio
and Eastern Kentucky
where coal mining happens
and those places profit from having
energy extracted and they also
at times pay a terrible price.
And so that's what I was interested
in exploring in this book.
Both the benefits of having
these rich natural resources
and the hidden costs.
So fracking is just
a piece of it really.
>> Jo Reed: Well, in
the book you taught,
Rich one of your main characters,
mentions that the kind of people
who take showers before they go
to work and the kind of people
who take showers when
they come home from work.
And one thing I like about your work
is you focus so often on the people
who take showers after work.
And that is very rare.
>> Jennifer Haigh:
Oh, it's very rare
and it's something
I care a lot about.
All of my work in one way
or another is about class,
it is the subject I keep coming
back to again and again and again.
I'm struck by how little of our
contemporary fiction actually deals
with working class people.
Almost none of it and
there are reasons for that.
A lot of it has to do with the sort
of futile system of publishing.
That publishing is such a
difficult field to make a living
in that young people
going into it kind
of can't do it without a trust fund.
You know, you get an entry
level job in publishing
that pays you $22,000 a year
and you're living in Manhattan
where your rent is you know, $3,000
a month, how do those numbers work?
Well, what happens is kids
from working class backgrounds
like myself do not go into
publishing and become editors
and so what you have in American
publishing is this sampling
of editors who are by and large from
comfortable backgrounds and tend
to be drawn to stories that evoke
the world that is familiar to them.
You know, it's subjective, what an
editor decides to publish has a lot
to do with what seems
relevant to her,
what reflects the world
back to her as she knows it.
So often young editors are going to
gravitate toward books about people
like themselves, it's a
natural human tendency.
If we had editors from working class
backgrounds we'd have more books
about working class people.
But that simply hasn't been the case
for at least the last generation.
So it is my subject
and it's something
that will probably always be my
subject by virtue of where I grew up
and the people I knew growing up.
>> Jo Reed: But the working
class people you can find them
in crime fiction.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Yes.
>> Jo Reed: No, really they exist.
That's where it happens.
Character, both of you have
[inaudible] created characters
as you mentioned Julia talking
about Jennifer's work where you --
the reader just knows
them immediately,
knows them intimately, very quickly.
What is the imaginative
mining or what you do
to get inside a character and
literally bring them to life?
>> Julia Glass: I get
to start I guess.
>> Jo Reed: I'm looking at you, yes.
Then I'm going to look at you.
>> Julia Glass: Well, I do go very,
very deep in fact I think about it
as a kind of mining but I take
my shower before I do the mining,
so [inaudible].
I've even had critics
write that I frequently,
not only do I write a lot of
flashback but I write flashbacks
within flashbacks and I have
characters examine not only what
they think of themselves but what
they think of what they think
of themselves and I've seen
quotations from my books
to prove it otherwise
I wouldn't believe it.
I do -- I'm only half joking when
I say the rhythm of my novels
and the way that I write is what I
call the psychotherapeutic rhythm.
And that is that I write
along in the present tense
in a character's mind for a while
and then I plummet into the past.
But I don't know when that's going
to happen and then I come back
to the present and then
I go back to the past.
So it's like being in
the therapist's office
and you're there complaining about
your day and how your boss was
such a brute to you, you
didn't get to take a full lunch
and you're complaining and
complaining and then there's a pause
and then the therapist says
does that boss remind you
of anybody else in your life?
And you use as a matter of fact
my mother when I was 16 years old.
And then you start
talking about your mother
when you were 16 years old and
then you return to the present.
And maybe you thrown in a dream
but I'm always [inaudible]
but I call myself the
flashback queen and it is
in my character's histories.
That the essence of
who they are emerges,
so I could not possibly
create the characters I do
without delving very
deeply into what --
where they come from,
who they come from.
The personal legacy, I
mean we talked about legacy
in a larger sense but
each of us is a legacy.
The writer Carol [inaudible].
>> Jo Reed: Shields.
Carol Shields wrote in one of her
novels a line that really moved me
and personally I find it very true,
she said every novel is the story
of the destiny of a child.
And in my work that rings
true, it may be many children
but each character's story
is inevitably going to touch
on their earliest life and
how they grew from there.
>> Jennifer Haigh: This is something
I really marvel at in Julie's work,
there's a real psychological acuity
here, the truth is we are all living
in the past, present and future
at the same time, at
every given moment.
I mean there's never been a
five minute block of your life
where you didn't think about
something that happened in the past
or what you're going
to have for dinner.
So we do this very naturally all the
time, this kind of time travelling
in our thoughts and Julie is
really very astute at getting
that on the page, the
kind of human capacity
to inhabit several different
times frames at once.
And I really appreciate
that in her characters.
>> Jo Reed: And well in Heat
and Light it was a
kaleidoscope of characters.
>> Julia Glass: That's
a great expression,
>> Jo Reed: That was
a lot to hold onto.
>> Jennifer Haigh: I'm never
going to do that again by the way,
this book almost killed me.
There are so many characters
whose head you get inside,
that was not initially
my plan for this book.
What happened was I set out
to write this fracking book
when I didn't really know
very much about the subject.
I knew a little bit and I
thought I had an opinion.
And what happened was the more
I learned about this question,
the more I realized how much
more I still needed to learn.
This is not a screed
against fracking,
it's important to make that point.
I would not write such a book and
I certainly wouldn't want to read
such a book, it's not that.
What I'm doing in this book
is trying to show accurately,
well this is how it is regardless
of your opinion on this question,
this is how it is to have a drill
rig 200 yards from your back door.
What's that like, it's
like this, you know.
What is it like to be a man who is
separated from his wife and family
for six months and living
basically a labor camp
and working 12 hour
shifts on a drill rig.
Well, this is what's that's like,
I'll show you what that's like.
So really that's what I'm doing it's
just sort of a camera and I'm kind
of showing all the facets of this
question and the reader is going
to draw her own conclusions
of course.
That's not my role as a novelist
to tell people what they
should believe about fracking.
I just want to show as
accurately as I can how it is.
And this is how I ended up with
this massive cast of characters
because every time I
learned something new
about this question I found myself
inventing a character who inhabits
that part of the argument.
So, I talked to a lot of
guys who worked on drill rigs
and I have a character
who works on a drill rig.
You know, I have a character
who is a CEO of a gas company,
I have a farmer who decides to lease
his mineral rights to a gas company.
And another farmer who
decides not to lease hers.
I have an environmental activist
and a geologist and you know,
all these people whose lives
are affected by this question.
It's not just the land owner, it's
people who work in the gas industry.
It's people who live in this
town and don't even own any land
but are effected by what it
does to their surroundings.
So that's how I ended up with
this very you know, populous novel
with a very complicated structure.
>> Jo Reed: But that's also
how you can write a book
that is political but not a screed.
But just a really remarkable story
where these characters
are alive and breathing.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Well, thank you,
you know, it's a discovery I made
in the writing of this book is that
there are no villains in this story.
I talked to people with a range
of opinions about fracking
and the conclusion I
came to is that every one
of these people has good
reasons for believing
as he believes and doing as he does.
There is no villain in this
story, these are people who act
for understandable reasons.
And I think particularly when you're
writing an issue book like this,
it's very important to make
readers see the humanity of people
who believe differently
from the way they do.
And you know, I did
not meet any villains
when I was doing the five
years of research for this book
and I didn't write any
villains in the novel.
>> Jo Reed: I want to
touch briefly on research,
because Julia you both do
research and for that book my lord,
I can't even begin to
imagine what that was like
and you wrote an essay
about research.
>> Julia Glass: Oh, the one I
wrote online for Random House?
>> Jo Reed: Yes.
>> Julia Glass: Oh,
you're a good detective.
>> Jo Reed: Thank you.
So what are your thoughts
about research,
when do you let the
research enter into the world
of the book that you're creating?
>> Julia Glass: For me it depends
on the book that I'm writing.
You know, if I were writing
the book like Heat and Light,
I think I'd have to undertake some
research early on or midway through.
But my general principle
is that I do research
as late as I possibly can.
And there are sort of two
main reasons for that, one,
is the I'm lazy and I'd rather
just live in my imagination
and imagine what it would be like.
For instance, I had a character who
was a pastry chef in one of my books
and all sorts of friends
said oh I know a pastry chef,
you can go spend a day
with a pastry chef.
Because I really love desert, you
know, I thought that would be great
because I didn't really
want to do it right away.
In fact I joked to my friends
the reason that I was writing
that novel is so that I could
order desert and call it research.
But I just, I faked
my way through it.
I imagined what I thought everything
was like, the construction
of a wedding cake and then I
did my research at the very end,
after I had drafted all these
important scenes involving the craft
of pastry.
And I was wrong about some
things but here's the thing,
and this is the second reason
I like to do my research late.
You know, I was that kid who loved
being in the library doing my --
and I wrote the class paper
that was five times as long
as everybody else's whether it
was on volcanos or you know,
I was actually obsessed
with volcanos.
I did one on volcanos and one
on Pompeii and Herculaneum.
So I just love finding
stuff out and the problem is
when you find really cool
stuff out you want to share it.
And you want to wedge it in there,
you want it to be in the novel
and maybe it doesn't belong there so
if you've already got the framework,
it's harder to squeeze in all these
really cool stories about the origin
of wedding cakes in
Hungary and Czechoslovakia
and the cool stuff I
found out by reading
about the history of wedding cakes.
And also their architectural
integrity and I'm sure
that if I were researching I'm
sure you found out a lot of stuff
that didn't have a
place in the book.
So how did you approach
it for this book?
>> Jennifer Haigh: Well, this
book I had to do some research
on the front end just to know
what I was talking about.
My favorite way of doing
research is interviews
and I interview obsessively, I
talk to lots and lots of people
and this has been true for
every novel I've written.
And it's -- yes it is research
but it's more than that.
I'm not looking for particular
information so much as I want
to hear the voices of people living
these different kinds of lives.
And I find that doing
a lot of interviews
on the front end suggests
possibilities for characters
that suggest possibilities
for story.
Not just you know, factual things
I need to know but once I start
to do research I see possibilities
in the story I wouldn't
have seen otherwise.
So for me it is integral
to the writing of it,
it's part of how I find the story.
And it's more true for some
novels than for others.
Heat and Light was a
massive research undertaking,
more so than I realized when
I started out writing it.
But you know, it was in the process
of doing research that I found a lot
of the story and I often
don't know what I'm looking
for when I set out looking.
You know, I just want somebody
to say something interesting.
And if I hear something that
fascinates me I'll follow it,
I give myself permission always to
follow the thread that fascinates.
Because I have to believe that if
I find something fascinating enough
that there's something in there the
reader will be fascinated by too.
So it's really you know, I'm casting
a very wide net in the beginning
when I do research, I don't
quite know what I'm looking for.
I'm hoping to find my
book out there somewhere.
>> Jo Reed: Do you work
closely with your editor?
>> Jennifer Haigh: Not on
the front end, no I don't.
I have a terrific editor
and I value him
and he's immensely
helpful with later drafts.
Nobody, nobody ever sees
my first draft of anything.
Nobody should ever have to.
My first drafts are hideous
and really I just want
to burn them always so I
don't share them with anyone.
I have a couple of readers
who will see maybe a second
or maybe a third draft,
never the first draft.
And my editor really sees a
fourth or a fifth draft maybe.
Part of the problem is I don't want
to know what anybody else thinks
until I know what I think.
You know, it really muddies
the water if you get opinions
from people before you've
solidified your own.
So I'm very, very cautious
about asking for feedback
and also cautious about
using up my good readers
because guess what you only get
somebody's first impression once.
If someone is a good friend
you know, he might be willing
to read it a second or third time
but he's never going to be able
to read it with those fresh eyes.
So I don't want to use up that
precious first reading from one
of my good readers until I'm
sure I've gotten it as far
as I can get it on my own.
>> Jo Reed: Julia do you work
closely with your editor?
>> Jennifer Haigh: Well,
I -- ditto what she said.
I love my editor and my weakness
is that every book that I turn
in to my editor when that draft
is really done has pretentions
of war and peace.
I turn in these massive things and
now they're done electronically
but I've been writing long enough
to have actually had to mail
in a manuscript in two UPS
boxes that weighed more
than my healthy, full
term first child.
So, and my editor is the
nicest person in the world
so she'll receive this and now
she'll receive it electronically
and it still blows my mind that
I push send and whoosh, you know,
800 pages goes over the cloud.
>> Jo Reed: Goes through the cloud.
>> Julia Glass: And she is
always complimentary at first
and she'll say, if you want
to publish an 800 page novel
then that's what we'll publish.
And I'm sure she's
lying through her teeth,
she knows I'm going
to say obviously not.
So and then we talk and what's
so interesting is the
first conversation we have
after she finishes the draft,
it's like we're gossiping
about friends of ours.
You know, like well I'm
not really convinced
that she fell in love with him.
I mean they're getting divorced
but when were they really in love?
And she will hone in on the things
that were missing and
also she'll say.
You know, we don't need to know
every single anecdote about so
and so's childhood like
when he lost his first tooth
and the first time he went
tobogganing and you know,
that first argument he had
with his mother when he was 16.
But she doesn't really lay
a pen on the manuscript,
we have a two hour conversation
and I go away and I know what needs
to go and I know what
needs to be sharpened too.
I like to say she's more of
a midwife than a surgeon.
And you know, so if my papers
were ever going to be of any value
to anybody they would be kind
of boring because you know,
she maybe cuts a comma
here and there
when it actually comes
to a written manuscript.
Is that more or less
true for your editor too
or is there a lot of
close line editing?
>> Jennifer Haigh: Well, you know,
it's because I'm sending in a draft
that I've been working on
for years that there isn't
so much on the line level.
There would be if I made
him read the first draft oh,
there would be blood on the page.
But I would never do that to him.
So it's really by the time he
gets it I've worked through a lot
of that on my own already.
>> Julia Glass: The other thing is
I used to, early on I would show
or even read out loud, this was
really bad, section to my husband
that I was very excited about.
First of all if I read them out loud
it would usually be after dinner
and I'd be reading and
then I'd hear this noise
and I thought that's
not snoring is it?
That's really not good for anybody.
But then the other thing is
if I gave it to him to read,
he would come away and say oh,
this character Carl is
that our friend Tom?
I'd go that is not our friend Tom
and then I'd go bad to working
on the book and all I
could think about is Tom.
So he doesn't get to see it any
sooner than anybody else does either
and some of my friends
think that's strange.
But no he does not get to see
it until my editor and my agent
and my husband all see
it at the same time.
>> Jo Reed: Jennifer you once said
that each book is an engineering
feat, that it has to work
and I was really intrigued by
that and I'd like you to say more.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Yeah,
absolutely, you know, I'm fascinated
by machines, I love writing about
machines and I think of a novel
as an extremely complicated machine.
The best comparison I can think
of, some of you are old enough
to remember this old board
game called Mouse Trap.
>> Julia Glass: Oh, I love that.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Who remembers
Mouse Trap, oh, like everyone.
Okay, so Mouse Trap for those
who don't know it the object
of the game is to build
this complicated,
ridiculous Rube Goldberg
type mouse trap
out of the dispirit plastic parts.
So there is like a rain gutter
and there's a stair case
and there's a crank you
turn and there's a bathtub
and these unlikely parts
that you string them together
and finally it's a trap
that will catch a mouse
in the most convoluted possible way.
That to me is the perfect
metaphor for writing a novel,
that you are building a story out
of found objects in a certain way
and it's a mechanism
that you want to be able
to flip a switch and have it work.
So when the first draft what I'm
doing is building this mousetrap
out of these dispirit parts.
Then what I'm doing afterward
is just testing and retesting
and retesting the trap until
it actually catches the mouse.
So I write a first draft, and I
kind of reverse engineer the thing
and I look at where are
the pinch points, you know,
where does the ball roll off track,
where do the gears get gummed
and I go in and fix those
in a very mechanistic way.
And then I run the trap again
and I find the ball gets stuck
in a different palce then I
go an diagnose those problems.
So it's a very -- my process
of revision is quite mechanical
and I really enjoy that.
You know, I think of a novel as
being like a car, I love cars
and I find cars beautiful.
But you know, when you turn the
key in the ignition all you care is
that the engine turns over.
So with a novel yeah you want
to build a beautiful machine
but the thing in the
end just needs to work.
So that's kind of what my
revision process looks like.
>> Jo Reed: Does that
make sense to you?
>> Julia Glass: I'm listening
really hard, I'm terrible with cars
so maybe I need to
pay more attention.
That's a fascinating metaphor and
you know, with my students you talk
about the engine turning over and
obviously I teach fiction writing
and the first thing that
I have my students do
for the first class is they have
to bring in the first page only
of a favorite short story or novel.
That they love in its entirety but
they really love the beginning too.
And we dissect that beginning
because I say if you don't start
in the right place, if you
don't pull the reader in
and I don't mean you
have to hook them
with a dead body or
anything like that.
I mean it may be language
that hooks them in,
it may be a lingering
question that's already there
on that first page.
Then you're already the
journey is off to a bad start.
So I focus a lot on that, you know,
is it beginning in the right place,
is it beginning in the right
tone and we dissect beginnings.
So I think that's kind of
like the engine turning over.
And then you know, after that
it's a lot more work of course.
I love what Sue Miller
said about writing a novel,
she said that writing a novel is
like knitting an argyle sock
the size of a football field.
Maybe that's more monotonous.
>> Jo Reed: And a word
about endings,
endings are very hard to accomplish.
How many go rounds do you
typically have to do before land
on what you think is the
palce you want to end.
>> Jennifer Haigh: I
find endings so difficult
that it makes me hate the
whole first draft of the book
because I'm living in fear that
I'm going to get the ending wrong.
You know, we've all had
this experience as readers
where you fall in love
with the book.
You fall in love with the
characters and the ending is
so horribly disappointing
that you want
to through the thing
across the room.
Now you will forever remember that
as a novel with the terrible ending.
You won't remember it as the
novel with the great beginning.
So it's kind of like you know, when
you're learning to fly a plane,
it's great if you have a
beautiful take off but if screw
up the landing no one is
going to remember that.
>> Julia Glass: Including you.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Very much like
that writing a novel, so I have lots
of anxiety around it and you know,
I usually do get the ending wrong
on the first draft, I don't know
that I've ever really gotten
it right on the first go.
So it is fraught and it is the
sort of thing that you keep writing
and writing and writing
until you find it.
>> Julia Glass: Well, the way
I write is I don't write draft,
after draft, after draft I write
forward back, forward back.
I think partly because
I'm so obsessive
about getting sentences right.
Things that I can't -- I'll
remember a sentence two pages ago
that just wasn't right.
So every time I sit down to write I
may intend to write ten more pages
but I may end up spending
three hours working
on the last ten pages that I wrote.
I don't make myself go forward
if I'm not going to get there.
So what happens is it really takes
me a long time to reach the end
and during that time I may
have had different ideas
about the ending I'm
going to arrive at.
But by the time I get to that last
chapter literally I've been working
on the book for probably at
least a year if not more.
And so I'm almost more
qualified to find the right end,
that doesn't mean it won't change
but I'm not doing first draft,
second draft, third
draft and so forth.
>> Jo Reed: And that leads exactly
to the question I wanted to ask
which is your both
midcareer novelist
with five or six novels each.
When you think back to
when you started writing
and the things you thought you'd be
exploring or that made you curious
or that drove you to the page, in
the first place do you see changes
from the writer you are now?
>> Julia Glass: Well, you know
talked about you would not return
to your town, to Pennsylvania.
And I was certain that
I would never return
to the characters in my first book.
Well, in fact some of them have
recurred in two further books.
So I never say never about anything.
I think that one thing
I've learned to do
through my books is I've
learned to be more forgiving
of myself, for one thing.
Not to be so scared
that I can't do it
because I've done it before, right.
So if I get stuck I don't get
as panicky, I also I did not go
to a MFA program or have any
creative writing training,
I actually majored in art in college
and I took only two English classes.
I didn't really like them, I mean
I was always good at writing.
But I really started writing
fiction seriously in my early 30's
and so all I had to go on were
essays I'd read about writing.
You know I bought writing guides
and I find that I absorbed
so many dogmatic pieces of advice
from writers whether they were
Stephen King or Anne Lamott.
That they didn't fit me
and I felt guilty or I felt
like I'm not a real writer
because I don't write every day.
Or I'm not a real writer
because I don't do this or that.
And I've learned that every
writer makes his or her own rules.
It doesn't mean you can't read
what other people have to say.
So I feel much more confident and
maybe able to take more chances.
But I also find that certain themes
come back again and again for me.
And I'm not one of those
writers who is going
to write the completely different
novel every time I sit down.
I think there are people like that.
I think Jennifer Egan is
one who really has a --
but you know the world of
paining and I returned to that.
I'm more like the painter
Morandi who I really revered
who did these amazing still
life's at variations on a theme
and I think that's
who I am as a writer.
So if I return, if characters
come back to me, if I write again
about New York in the plague
years which is something I seem
to return to again and again.
Then that's who I am and I
occupy that territory more
and more confidently I think and not
feeling like I need to make excuses
if I write about the same thing.
>> Jo Reed: You still have questions
about it that you want to explore.
>> Julia Glass: I do, yeah.
>> Jo Reed: Jennifer?
>> Jennifer Haigh: You know
when I was writing my first novel
I had no idea what I was doing.
It's writing the first novel is kind
of like running the first marathon.
You're not trying to
win you just don't want
to die while you're doing it.
So my goal was just to live through
the writing of that first novel
and to write a book
that I'd want to read.
You know, I don't have particularly
exotic tastes as a reader
and I figure if it's
a book that I want
to read then somebody somewhere else
is going to want to read it also.
So that's all I was trying to do
is live through the writing process
and write a book that
I would want to read.
As I've gotten further
along you know,
I'm drawn to some different
subjects I guess.
But that's still really the guiding
principle to me to write a book
that I would want to read.
When I wrote my first novel
I thought okay it's going
to be easier now.
You know, now I know
how to write a novel,
it will never be this hard again.
I was entirely wrong about that.
What I learned was yes I
know how to write a novel
but I only know how
to write that novel.
And the lessons I learned were
not particularly portable,
I could not apply them to my
second or my third or my forth.
So in a certain way it's starting
at zero every time for me, you know,
I always feel like I'm an imposter,
I am completely unqualified
to do this.
>> Julia Glass: Well, I think we
all -- what we do is so weird,
we just sit there and make stuff up
like why are we doing this thing.
So I certainly have those
moments of like what
in the world am I doing here.
But don't you feel having
completed, like don't you get,
like I say in the middle
of the ocean
where you can't see the horizons
on either side and you don't know
if you have enough
water to make it across.
Don't you tell yourself
I've done this before
and I know I'll do it again, or
does it really feel like starting
from zero again each time?
>> Jennifer Haigh:
Certainly the first year,
the first year it absolutely
does, yeah.
>> Jo Reed: Okay and
there we have to leave it
because time has gotten away.
>> Jennifer Haigh: Okay.
>> Jo Reed: Julia Glass
her most recent book is,
A House Among the Trees.
And Jennifer Haigh, Heat and
Light just came out in paperback,
thank you, it was wonderful,
thank you.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.